[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild Luise
[Musik]
29.082010 bis
12.032023 unser Haus so
still ein Platz für immer
leer lises brutaler Tod hat zu
unsagbarem Schmerz geführt durch die
unzähligen Zeichen der Anteilnahme
Trauer und Hilfsbereitschaft haben wir
von Anfang an gespürt dass wir nicht
allein sind von ganzem Herzen danken wir
euch allen für eure Unterstützung in der
schlimmsten Zeit unseres Lebens danke
für die schnelle Beteiligung und
riesengroße Unterstützung aller
Einsatzkräfte und freiwilligen Helfer
die Tag und Nacht alles gegeben haben
unsere Luise zu
finden danke an die Kriminalpolizei und
besonders an die Abteilung Opferschutz
die uns jederzeit zur Seite stehen danke
an Pastor iewski die wundervollen
Menschen der Pietät Siegen und den
vielen anderen die mit vereinten Kräften
alles möglich gemacht haben damit wir
alle von Luisa Abschied nehmen konnten
hab Dank für jedes liebe Wort jede
Umarmung jeden stummen Blick wenn
einfach die Worte fehlen Luises Tod hat
uns Alleen noch mal gezeigt worauf es im
Leben ankommt aufeinander aufpassen
Respekt Zusammenhalt und fürinander da
sein wenn alles zerbricht die Freude
unsere Träume das gemeinsame Leben so
zählt dann das was wirklich wichtig ist
die
Liebe Luise du wirst für immer in
unseren Herzen
bleiben das ist die Traueranzeige für
die zwjährige Luise aus Freudenberg im
nordrheinwestfähischen Siegerland das
hier ist ein ganz besonderer Fall und
wir werden ihn ein bisschen anders
erzählen als in den meisten anderen
Episoden ich bin Stefan Netzeband hallo
und ich bin Mirko Kasimir schön dass ihr
dabei seid wir haben in dieser Reihe
über ganz unterschiedliche Verbrechen
berichtet über unfassbare Mordserien
über skurile historische Gewalttaten
über schockierende Tötungen aus
Leidenschaft oder die Kranken Auswüchse
von Geldgier und ruhmessucht aber wir
hatten noch nie einen Fall der einen so
ratlos hinterlässt wie dieser
hier Freudenberg im März
2023 Bildreporter Jörg
fölkerling 12 Stunden lang suchten die
Einsatzkräfte in der Nacht auf Sonntag
nach der Vermis zjährigen Luise bevor
sie dann am Sonntag Vormittag an diesem
Abhang in die Tiefe blickten und den
leblosen Körper der Vermissten Schülerin
entdeckten die sanitäter und
Feuerwehrleute arbeiteten sich dann
mühsam zu ihr vor sie dachten zunächst
sie sei gefallen gestürzt sie entdeckten
auch eine
Sprunggelenksverletzung einen Bruch doch
als dann die Experten von der grippo
Gerichtsmedizin näher kam entdeckten sie
zahlreiche Einstiche am ganzen Körper
und es war noch Ort relativ schnell klar
dass hier wohl ein Gewaltverbrechen
vorliegen müsste am Montag morgen um
10:30 Uhr kam dann auch tatsächlich die
Bestätigung von Polizeipräsidium in
koblinz Luisas Tod war Mord so berichtet
der Bildjournalist aus dem Wald bei
Freudenberg aus einer Region die selten
Schlagzeilen
macht aus historische
Stadtkerne nicht weit entfernt von den
großen Metropolen am rein liegt die
romantische Fachwerkstatt Freudenberg im
historischen Stadt kernalterflecken
reihen sich giebelständige
Fachwerkhäuser in Viererreihen
aneinander eingebettet in eine herrlich
grüne Wald und Wiesenlandschaft können
Besucher auf zahlreichen Wander und
Radwegen die Region erkunden viele
kleine Stadtteile und Orte freudenbergs
begeistern mit idylischen Plätzen
historischen Kirchen und beeindruckenden
Aussichten über das
Siegerland ein besonderes Highlight im
Freudenberg ist der Frühlingsmarkt mit
Seifenkistenrennen im April der Herbst
und Mittelaltermarkt im Oktober sowie
der Freudenberger advent am 1
Adventswochenende sind ebenfalls einen
Besuch
wert weit entfernt von irgendwelchen
Feierlichkeiten ist die Stadt nach dem
Leichenfund im Wald die Bildzeitung am
14 März
2023 wer hat dort Luisa ermordet
Freudenberg ein vom Regen auf geweichter
Radweg ein steiler Abhang und dichter
Wald drum herum nichts erinnert an
diesem Montag noch daran dass hier in
der Nähe eines früheren Bahnhofs nur
einen Tag zuvor die Leiche der
zwölfjährigen Luise aus Freudenberg
entdeckt wurde doch die Einwohner des
städtchenens sind schockiert denn nun
ist klar die Siebtklässlerin wurde
ermordet die bisher durchgeführten
Ermittlungen bestätigen den Verdacht
dass das Mädchen Opfer eines
Tötungsdeliktes geworden ist sagte ein
Sprecher der
Staatsanwaltschaft aber was ist passiert
rätselhaft Luise kam von ihrer Freunden
doch ihre Leiche wurde nicht auf dem Weg
nach Hause gefunden sondern fast in
entgegengesetzter Richtung ob der
Fundort auch der Tatort ist war gestern
noch unklar ebenso ob ein knapp 400 m
langer ehemaliger Eisenbahntunnel eine
Rolle spielt der sich nur wenige hundert
Meter vom Fundort entfernt befindet die
des Mädchens sollte gestern noch
obduziert werden bislang schwieg die
Polizei zur
Todesursache laut den Angaben der
Ermittler handelt es sich wohl nicht um
ein Sexualverbrechen offen bleibt die
Frage wann und wo traf Luise ihren
Mörder der ungeklärte Mord an einem
zjährigen Mädchen erlässt aus der Ferne
zumindest vielerlei Möglichkeiten zu
innerfamiliäre Probleme Trennung dren
z.B oder die Kranke Lust irgendeines
gestörten Erwachsenen die Lösung aber
ist auf ganz andere Weise
schockierend 14 März Pressekonferenz von
Polizei und Staatsanwaltschaft in
koblinz es spricht der Leitende
Oberstaatsanwalt Mario
Mannweiler nach dem Ergebnis der
Ermittlungen müssen wir nach derzeitigen
Stand jedenfalls davon ausgehen dass die
Tat von zwei Kindern begangen worden
ist aus dem bekannten Kreis des
Opfers das ergibt sich sowohl aus der
objektiven Beweislage als auch aus dem
Inhalt der Anhörungen die wir von den
beiden äh durch geführt
haben aufgrund des kindlichen Alters der
mutmaßlichen
Täter Rinnen
ähm gehen wir von Strafunmündigkeit aus
es ist ein Fall der ist natürlich
erschütternd es ist uns allen klar das
trifft für uns genauso zu wie für Sie
alle
das bedeutet aber in der Konsequenz
zunächst einmal für uns als
Staatsanwaltschaft und Polizei dass
keine strafrechtlichen Sanktionen
erfolgen können weil das Gesetz das
verbietet und die beiden Kinder jetzt in
die ophut des Jugendamtes gegeben worden
sind das auch für alle weit men zunächst
erst zuständig
ist ein Beben geht bundesweit durch die
Presse Kinder ermorden Kinder was ist
bloß los was stimmt mit unserem
Nachwuchs nicht am schlimmsten fühlt
sich der Schock natürlich vor Ort an
Bildreporter Jörg völkerling in der Nähe
des Schulzentrums von Freudenberg an
normalen Unterricht ist hier an der
estaro Gesamtschule natürlich nicht zu
denken zumal Opfer und Täterin dies e
die siebte Klassenstufe besucht haben
Schulpsychologen versuchen jetzt ein
bisschen den Schülern beizustehen und
auch die Trauerarbeit zu bewältigen
neben dem ganz normalen
Unterricht währenddessen wird immer mehr
gemutmaßt was diese beiden 12 und
13-jährigen zu dieser horrortat
getrieben haben mag es ist davon Mobbing
die Rede angeblich soll sich Lise bei
einer Lehrkraft beschwert haben dass sie
gemobt würde diese Lehrerin soll nichts
unternommen haben gleich wohl sollen die
beiden späteren Täterinnen sich dann
durch dieses
messerattentat quasi an ihrer
Mitschülerin gerecht
haben es stellt sich also langsam heraus
die Tat hatte eine Vorgeschichte und bei
den Täterinnen hat es wohl durchaus eine
Planung für die Rache an Luise gegeben
Bild am Tag nach der Trauerfeier am 25
März am Mittwochabend nahm die stadt
Freudenberg bei einem feierlichen
Gottesdienst Abschied von der ermordeten
Schülerin Luise jetzt werden neue
schockierende Details zu der Tat bekannt
offenbar haben die beiden kindlichen
Täterinnen 12 und 13 Jahre alt den Mord
gut vorbereitet und sich genau erkundigt
was ihnen droht laut Bildinformationen
hat die Polizei die Handys der beiden
Mädchen beschlagnahmt und ausgewertet
dabei entdeckten die Ermittler Spuren
die belegen dass die Täterinnen im
Internet nach dem Stichwort
Strafunmündigkeit suchten Hintergrund
offenbar war den beiden Mädchen bewusst
dass man erst mit 14 Jahren
strafrechtlich für seine Taten belangt
und vor Gericht verurteilt werden kann
BILD erfuhr weiter die Messerattacke auf
Louise soll bereits mindestens mehrere
Tage vorher geplant worden sein aufgrund
der bisherigen Ermittlungen geht die
Polizei davon aus dass die zwölfjährige
die Haupttäterin ist sie soll Streit mit
Luise gehabt haben ihre Komplizin hielt
Luise offenbar fest während die
zwölfjährige immer wieder
Zach Jörg wölkerling im Wald bei
Freudenberg ein Abgrund in Sichtweite am
Sieg bigeradweg beginnen die letzten
Meter von Lise vor ihrem Tod hier muss
sie am Samstagabend gegen 19 Uhr mit den
beiden Klassenkameraden unterwegs
gewesen sein entgegengesetzt ihres
normalen Heimweges es ist eine ziemlich
abgeschiedene Gegend an der Landesgrenze
zwischen Nordrhein-Westfalen und
rheinlandpalz hier wenn man mal nach
unten schaut und ist ist eine 10 m tiefe
Schlucht unten ist der Wildenburger Bach
der hier entlang rauscht und auf den
Hängen sieht man noch die Spuren
vergangene Orkane umgestürzte Bäume und
ein sehr unwiegksames Gelände kein Handy
Empfang nachts ist hier kein Licht so
kann man sich auch vorstellen vor
welcher Herausforderung die
Suchmannschaften standen in den Stunden
nachdem Louise vermisst gemeldet worden
ist sie ist dann etwa 200 m weiter äh in
einer Schlucht gefunden worden von den
Rettern da kam aber schon jede Hilfe für
sie zu
spät Focus online über den
Tattag Samstag 11 März am Nachmittag die
beste Freundin des Opfers meldet sich
telefonisch bei den Eltern lises gegen
17:30 Uhr dabei gab die 13-Jährige
Klassenkameradin aus der 7D der
örtlichen Gesamtschule an dass Louise
sich auf dem Nachhauseweg befinde vom
Wohnort der Freundin bis zum Elternhaus
sind es 3 km zu Fuß als Luise nicht
heimkehrte schalteten ihre Angehörigen
die Polizei ein eine großangelegte
vermiststenfandung nahm ihren Lauf so
durchkämmte eine Einsatzhundertschaft
das Unwirkliche Wandergebiet namens
klein Tirol personenspürhunde sogenannte
Mantrailer suchten nach dem Mädchen ein
Hubschrauber scannte das Areal mit einer
Wärmebildkamera ab Drohnen überflogen
das
Gelände was ist in den Täterinnen
vorgegangen beim Mord die Psychologin
Heike Wagner Hollatz die zahlreichen
messertiche lassen die Hypothese zu dass
die täterinen zum Tat Zeitpunkt
emotional hochgradig aufgeregt waren
da war eine hohe Emotion dabei da war
kein wirklich kognitives kalkuliertes
denken mehr möglich sondern die Täterin
Staren immer und immer wieder zu obwohl
ihre mitschüderin ja bereits verwundet
war es könnte sogar sein dass es ihnen
aber auch ganz wichtig war dass Louise
wirklich stirbt vielleicht hatten sie
große Angst dass Louise sonst
auspackt dass die Tat Ihnen ein bisschen
aus dem Ruder gelaufen ist und sie
wollten ganz sicher sein dass Louise
niemand erzählen kann dass sie beiden
die Täterinnen sind für die Presse gibt
es von Vorort jetzt viel weniger zu
berichten als bei anderen Mordfällen
denn Opfer und Täter sind Kinder es gibt
keine entlichen hafttermine oder
Anhörungen dafür wird im Land viel und
erregt diskutiert ist der Fall wirklich
so besonders so
einmalig der Kriminologe Christian
Pfeifer bei
welttv wird mal erst mit den
Jugendlichen vergleichen die sind ja
Alters näher dann sehen wir dass es
schon einen riesen Unterschied gibt
zwischen Kindern und Jugendlichen bei
den Jugendlichen kommen vorsätzliche
Tötungsdelikte einschließlichte
versuchten taten oh jah 30 40 50 Mal vor
und bei den Mädchen hier hat's zuletzt
Jahre gegeben wo kein einziges Mädchen
mit tödlicher Absicht jemand anders
verletzt hat oder gar getötet hat also
sind schon
riesen Unterschiede in der Entwicklung
diese beiden Mädchen die nun hier als
Täterinnen
feststehen sind eine extreme Ausnahme
also diese Geschichte die sich hier in
Freudenberg geeignet hat ist fast
einmalig wie kann es sein dass Kinder
die so etwas tun nicht bestraft werden
muss das Gesetz geändert werden ja
findet bildkommentator Gunna Schupelius
es kann nicht so weitergehen wir haben
die Zahlen gesehen es gibt jede Menge
unter 14-Jährige die schwere Straftaten
begehen und die Zahl der Tatverdächtigen
nimmt enorm zu und es ist überhaupt
nicht abzusehen dass diese Tendenz
abschwächt dass sich sie abschwächt
sondern im Gegenteil die Tendenz ist
zunehmend es muss etwas geschehen es
kann nicht so bleiben die
Strafmündigkeit muss gesenkt werden die
Psychologin ist skeptisch die Tatsache
dass zwölfjährige in den USA als
strafmündig eingeschätzt werden und bei
uns hier in Deutschland nicht liegt
einfach daran dass wir in jedem Land das
eigene Rechtssystem haben und in Amerika
wird vielleicht eher darauf geguckt eine
Art Abschreckung zu erzeugen man hofft
darauf wenn die Strafmündigkeit äh weit
unten ist dass Täter abgeschreckt werden
wir wissen aber aus vielen Ländern dass
dies nicht der Fall ist und hier in
Deutschland ist es so dass wir eher den
Blick darauf wenden ist ein Kind als
Täter wirklich schuldfähig können wir
jemand der 11 12 Jahre alt ist überhaupt
schon als Täter
ansehen Straßenumfrage der Bildreporter
in Berlin im März 2023
kann nicht sein dass zjährige oder
13-jährige eine zjährige Mitschülerin
umbringen da sollte dann das Gesetz
schon anders greifen glaube ich ich sag
mal für für schwere Straftaten würde ich
es mir überlegen für geringere sollten
Sie eine Chance bekommen dass er sich
auf de richtigen Weg begeben also das
richtig dass nicht belangt werden weil
ich glaube dass man mit dem Alter noch
nicht sagen die Verantwortung hat ich
finde es sollte härter bestraft seden
auch bei Jugendlichen und wenn nötig
sogar die Eltern wer für mich ist da
großes Versagen der
Eltern nicht der Gesellschaft also
verurteilt müssen Sie auf jeden Fall ich
weiß jetzt nicht ob kann man jetzt nicht
eine Zelle sperren und damit ist die
Sache gelöst und dann nach ein paar
Jahren oder kommen sie raus und da muss
man glaube ich anders vorgehen weil den
auch gar nicht wirklich bewusst ist was
Sie vielleicht gemacht haben also dieses
es hat sich glaub ich wcheinlich
hochgeschaukelt aber ich glaube wenn man
jetzt wirklich psychologisch darauf ist
es denn gar nicht bewusst oder haben die
gar nicht das Urteilsvermögen gehabt das
einzuschätzen was sie gemacht haben wann
würde ich den beden mdelsen irgendeiner
Einrichtung ja auf sozialer Ebene das
wirklich mal ins Jahre eine
Erziehungsmaßnahme
ja Haftanstalt wi ich nicht ob das was
bringt die Zeitung die Welt am
12.9.2023 Ermittlungen im Fall Luisa
eingestellt
Strafunmündigkeit ein halbes Jahr nach
dem gewaltsamen Tod der zwöjährigen
Luisa aus dem nordrheinwestfälischen
freudenberg hat die Staatsanwaltschaft
Siegen die Ermittlungen eingestellt
grund dafür sei die Strafunmündigkeit
der Tatverdächtigen Mädchen tealten die
Ermittler mit eine Anklage oder einen
Prozess wird es damit nicht
geben Einschätzung des Rechtsanwaltes
Alexander Stevens die Chancen dafür dass
die mutmaßlichen TäterInnen wieder ein
ganz normales Leben anfühungszeichen
führen können werden stehen dennoch
nicht schlecht weil das Strafrecht schon
gar nicht anwendbar ist wird es z.B
überhaupt nicht zu irgendwelchen
negativen Eintragungen in ein
Führungszeugnis ein Erziehungsregister
ins Bundeszentralregister kommen das zum
einen zum anderen darf man auch nicht
vergessen dass der Schutz eines
Jugendlichen und es recht hier bei
Kindern extrem hoch wiegt das bedeutet
es dürfen keine nähere Angaben zu den
beiden mutmaßlichen TäterInnen gemacht
werden der Fall Luise hat eine Familie
an den Abgrund geführt eine Schule
schockiert und eine unspektakuläre Stadt
in die agzahen gebracht und er hat eine
Diskussion über Kinder in unserem
Strafrecht ausgelöst ich persönlich
halte es für völlig unsinnig nach
solchen Taten mal schnell einfach das
Gesetz zu ändern was bitte genau soll
denn danach passieren aber wir haben ja
gehört dass es dazu viele
unterschiedliche Meinungen gibt aber
schreibt uns gern was ihr über den Fall
denkt oder über das Thema
Strafmündigkeit und auch gerne über die
Art wie wir den Fall diesmal erzählt
haben wir freuen uns über euer Feedback
auf allen bekannten podcastplattform per
E-Mail an
podcast@bild.de oder neuerdings auch
über WhatsApp die Nummer dazu findet ihr
in den Show Notes bis zum nächsten Fall
euer Mirko und euer
Stefan dir hat diese Folge von tout
Deutschland gefallen du bekommst von
True Crime einfach nicht genug dann hör
jetzt in unsere weiteren Folgen rein
hier warten mehr als 200 spannende Fälle
auf dich das Verschwinden von Rebecca
Rusch der Prozess gegen OJ Simpson oder
die Entführung von ursela Hermann wir
hören uns bei Tat Deutschland